en conséquence j'en suis j'en suis
persuadée par contre
ma crainte était plutôt à l'effet que ça
finisse par avoir des répercussions sur
moi dans les coulisses dans les
corridors de sentir que la petite
nouvelle dans le fond était venue était
venu causer du trouble parmi parmi les
reins et j'étais là moi seulement depuis
quelques mois lui il était là depuis
plus d'une trentaine d'années dans le
parti il était apprécié il était l'ami
de tout le monde en fait pendant un an
et demi elle côtoie régulièrement son
agresseur
préserlections en 2018 on est un très
petit coquilles quand même c'est ça donc
les contacts étaient nécessairement
encore plus encore plus fréquent j'étais
mal à l'aise dans dans le contexte
disait que je serai désormais assez de
députés souvenir indépendante il s'agit
d'une question de transparence et de
sincérité pour me donner les coups de
France dans cette démarche est-ce que ça
pesait dans la balance justement dans
votre décision de quitter le particulier
ça m'a pas retenu ça me paraît bien
évidemment les raisons pour lesquelles
je suis devenue député indépendante
elles étaient avant tout politique c'est
certain que j'avais un certain
soulagement
dans dans le fait de prendre de prendre
mes distances en fait que ça me
permettait également de couper les ponts
de façon plus définitive avec cette
cette personne là
j'ai vraiment rien à reprocher au parc
québécois dans cette histoire là
absolument rien parce que j'ai pas
dénoncé la station à l'interne du parti
mais le traumatisme la rattrape et elle
finit par porter plainte deux ans et
demi après l'agression parce qu'on veut
oublier qu'on oublie donc
malheureusement j'ai eu beaucoup de
difficultés de plus en plus à vivre avec
ces événements là j'avais une crainte
également je mettais je prends pas la
parole si je dénonce pas si tu arrives
quelque chose
je vais m'en vouloir toute ma vie
Harold Lebel est arrêté en décembre 2020
le jour même Catherine Fournier est
dévastée lorsque son nom est dévoilé
dans les médias malgré une ordonnance de
non publication imposée par le tribunal
le procès à l'automne dernier était
prouvant mais le jury la croix et
déclare l'ex député coupable d'agression
sexuelle le secret de polichinelle a
assez duré pour Catherine Fournier à la
lumière de l'expérience que vous avez
vécue est-ce que vous recommandez aux
victimes d'agression sexuelle de porter
plainte je suis fière de l'avoir de
l'avoir fait je suis satisfait de mon
expérience j'ai eu un accompagnement
vraiment
exemplaire à travers à travers tout ça
je sens que j'ai été bien soutenu par le
système le message que j'aimerais lancer
c'est si les personnes victimes sont le
choix de passer à travers le système
judiciaire il y a des ressources qui
sont là qui sont en place j'en ai
bénéficié je peux en témoigner et elles
sont vraiment précises est-ce qu'il y a
quelque chose dans le piment politique
de l'époque et actuel serait pas très
longtemps qui rend propice ce type
d'agression que vous avez vécu il y en a
dans tous les milieux mais je pense que
le milieu politique en raison de la
promiscuité en raison des rapports de
pouvoir puis en raison également de
l'espèce d'omerta qui fait en sorte que
lorsqu'on milite pour une formation
politique on souhaite que cette
formation politique bénéficie d'une
image qui poussive ces trois facteurs là
rendre rendons le favorise ce genre de
situation là qu'est-ce qui pourrait être
fait pour prévenir d'autres situations
comme celles que vous avez vécues c'est
certain que je pense que s'il y avait un
répondant plus indépendants en matière
de violence à caractère sexuel
qui pourrait être interpellé à
l'extérieur des formations
politiques
ce serait évidemment plus plus adéquat
parce que de penser qu'une personne
victime va aller se confier ou va aller
demander aux 8 ou chef du parti moi je
pense que c'est que c'est pas réaliste
alors le Bel est passé devant la
commission délibération conditionnelle
récemment il y a eu sa libération au
quart de sa peine il y avait une peine
de huit mois est-ce que vous lui
Pardonnez ce qui vous a fait
je pense qu'elle pardon c'est un
processus qui peut qui peut prendre du
temps j'espère y arriver je pense je
pense que je vais que je vais y arriver
éventuellement merci Merci à VOUS ICI
Geneviève Garon Radio-Canada Longueuil